when you're in an environment and it
speaks to you you actually feel better
in this space you like seeing people
laying out on the beach for instance or
sitting out picnic tables and having
that shared space where you can walk and
say hey can I sit here - that's how you
really make connections network you
never know who you may meet and that's
one of the best things about seeing you
what campus involves some of the best
drama students as well as some of the
best engineers and then artists if you
put them together bouncing ideas off
each other it's pretty special we kind
of imagined this specific space as an
electronics and sewing room I along with
two other students spent half of spring
semester basically kind of talking to
people around who might be using these
spaces talking to more wood resonance
then kind of planning out what we
thought this space should be and how to
actually make it more of a makerspace
and they had all these tools but they
were just kind of hidden behind the
walls so we thought like okay the first
thing is to first expose the tools you
know like walking by if you see the
tools all of a sudden you see students
be like oh hey that's cool I can use
this what can I do with this space I
think a lot of times people look at a
campus like Carnegie Mellon and they say
you know it's been placed here we go
through the system and then we finish
but if you're a student is able to shape
how the campus comes together that can
change the students experience
completely as a student I definitely
believe that architecture and urban
design influences the way we live our
lives and how happy we are in a space
and with CMU's new approach to create in
a campus that it was really engaging for
the students and promotes healthy
lifestyles they really want students who
are passionate about this to go out
there seeing what other students want
and really start to understand how we
can better the campus as a whole